les médailles de bronze de l'équipe de
france de concours complet récolter le
week-end dernier aux championnats
d'europe en écosse on ne pouvait rêver
de meilleur symbole pour l'arrivée de
l'équitation de haut niveau à lamotte
beuvron une évolution du site voulu et
préparé par la fédération française
il s'avère année après année que la
fédération a un outil qu'elle maîtrise
cet outil est que ça semble la meilleure
des options de pouvoir conforter et
capitalisées du conte tout au travail
tous nos efforts tous nos
investissements en un même lieu pour
pouvoir accueillir l'ensemble des
cavaliers de france ils étaient 29
cavaliers à s'élancer sur les 3300 trop
mètres de la nouvelle piste de cross
un parcours spectaculaire avec 32 saut
pour les meilleurs couples français sur
un sol totalement refait pour les
chevaux tous les sables n'ont pas la
même qualité et non pas le même
répondant pour sauter vous voyez quand
on est sur des sables mous les chevaux
sont très mal donc on peut pas faire sur
les sables le mood en colère un sable
qui se compacte bien mais bon
apparemment ils ont choisi vraiment le
bon sol et qu'ils sont très satisfaits
du résultat
un cross récit muet très rapide avec des
combinaisons et deux gays qui ont
nécessité beaucoup de franchise de la
part des chevaux
mathieu lemoine termine 4e ce soir avant
l'ultime étape de concours hippique
demain auréolé de sa médaille de bronze
aux championnats d'europe
le cavalier de sandillon espère rester
en selle jusqu'aux jo de rio jeux
olympiques à la fois c'est très loin
encore il peut se passer beaucoup de
choses à la fois c'est très proche est
trop proche pour former encore un autre
cheval
donc on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
alors je sais pas si j'ai gagné des
points blair castle en tout cas je sais
que j'en ai pas perdu
en attendant le cavalier peut espérer un
podium demain dans cette ultime étape
des championnats de france